Gavin Newsom and just today he announced
that he wants to push forward a 28th
amendment that will uh kind of enact
some quote unquote Common Sense gun
regulations across the land uh and uh I
did pull a a clip from his his
announcement of that that I was curious
to get your reaction to and then we can
speak a little bit more about California
after that but first let's hear from
Gavin Newsom
every time it's the same they tell us we
can't stop these massacres they tell us
we have to stand by and watch tragedy
after tragedy unfold in our communities
they say we can't stop domestic
terrorism without violating the Second
Amendment and the thoughts and prayers
are the best we can do
I'm here to say that's a lie so today
I'm proposing the 28th Amendment to the
United States Constitution to do just
that it raises the minimum age to
purchase a firearm from 18 to 21. it
mandates Universal background checks and
institutes reasonable waiting periods
for all gun purchases and it bans
civilians from buying assault rifles
pose weapons of war our founding fathers
never foresoft this will guarantee
States as well the ability to enact
Common Sense gun safety laws while
leaving the Second Amendment intact and
respecting America's gun owning
tradition for the last two years I've
seen Newsome in particular do this weird
rebranding of
I don't know the so-called positive
Liberties as the real definition of
freedom or something so I don't know if
you guys recall his little campaign but
he's like well actually freedom in
California means the right to have an
abortion you know paid for and the right
to be free you've gone violence and you
know it's part of this like I don't know
I I think he imagines it as like it's
California competing against Florida in
in a persuasive redefinitions of what
like American Liberty actually means and
maybe that's sophisticated but I don't
really get the angle other than um it's
just a convenient way for people to
embrace the pink police state or
something uh and of course we all know
what his 28th Amendment thing here means
it's just a clever way of saying
liberals will always like to pretend to
be originalists or constitutionalists
when they when they grab your guns you
know it's it's pretty vulgar to me
that's my initial reaction yeah I I
wonder about and I just I'm always
wondering you know you're because you're
you're playing you're constantly playing
this game where you're trying to stay a
step ahead of what they're going to do
next and at the moment it appears you
you are a step ahead because they're
still fighting over these 80 receivers
and you've created the zero percent
receiver so that conversation seems to
be in different stages right now but
what one thing that California seems to
be trying to do to get get after this
problem is uh to use liability laws uh
to hold either gun uh manufacturers or
gun sellers liable for
uh any shootings that happen with the
guns uh and what one example here uh
just earlier this week LAPD found 700
ghost guns now it's getting five million
dollars basically they uh recovered uh
ghost guns that were used in the ambush
of some LA county sheriff's deputies in
Compton and a home invasion and a triple
murder and uh they settled with polymer
80 which is a competing ghost gun kit
seller for five million dollars so does
seeing stories like this worry you that
kind of that that's ultimately going to
be the fate of Defense distributed that
people are going to use ghost guns to
commit crimes and then they're going to
somehow try to come after you and hold
you liable if it could be traced back to
it was created on a ghost Gunner
well unfortunately or not this is
already our reality it's not like this
hasn't happened yet Paul and Rady's
taking most of these hits these days and
I agree with you on the general approach
both of gun control and like State and
municipal authorities they imagine a
better like big tobacco-like approach
where okay the big the biggest suppliers
let's say Smith and Wesson the actual
gun suppliers they at least have the pro
forma protection of What's called the
placa and if you guys know about the
placa but you know protection of lawful
Commerce and arms act something like
that so okay well they can't you know
they're still trying to pierce it right
because um you'll remember the big
Remington settlement after Sandy Hook
and that that itself was was a pretty
sad thing because like the insurers
decided to settle they didn't decide to
press the issue on the plaque or the 2A
and so I have seen consortiums you know
like illegal meats or these gun
controllers get together and say all
right our new strategy is placa we can
at least beat them all up in court and
get the insurance carriers to settle so
much that it forces you know as good
capitalists at 4 forces them to make a
safer product they'll label it
differently they'll put you know weird
orange tips and safety features on the
guns and things so that's in Earnest
their approach and of course it gives
them this pro-social whatever this kind
of progressive feeling about it while it
also masks I guess the it's pure
ideology but it also masks how well
they're actually engaging in gun control
by capitalism now rather than like
strictly as a kind of ideological
approach but uh back to your point I've
been in California alone I've also been
sued I was sued in the tahama ghost gun
shooting and a number of ghosting
companies were sued
um including Black Hawk we were sued for
500 million I think
half a billion dollars you know yeah you
get concerned when you're sued for half
a billion dollars anytime someone
has a uses a ghost gun so
uh to to the point in the in the article
you just previewed well the accusation
that they don't do background checks
um this is a this is a problem right
there again they're trying to redefine
the duty of care of a ghost gun company
that company's not selling guns that
company can't use the Knicks system
even if it wanted to uh and so a little
bit you know this is all workshop for PR
this is all kind of part of a broader
campaign of pushing people in this
direction to make expectations have
expectations like the big tobacco fight
this is my read about it but to your
point will will this be the future of if
yes of course as as these kit guns are
used and crimes and things yes I think
we'll be hauled into every single Court
we're often threatened of it there was a
big New York suit very recently that
brought a bunch of suppliers in I think
we weren't brought in because at this
point
um we have a reputation for being
very litigious like they don't always
want to just litigate with us so they
kind of pick lower hanging fruit maybe
or softer targets uh but you know like
I've gotten plenty of behind the scenes
private letters from Leticia James pick
your favorite AG you know like they're
always threatening to do and that will
be the future that the chunk of metal
that you have you know at what point
does that become a gun uh and does it
stop being uh you know uh merely a block
of metal these these are the most
interesting questions and to use your
analogy like the drug or scheduling
analogy like that's I saw California now
other states are beginning to use
a War on Drugs vocabulary to regulate
gun components and this is so much fun
they say precursor parts right precursor
parts to fire yeah the connotation is
already there that like there's
something wrong that you would have
components that might go into a gun or
fit into a gun and there's something
implied about the scheduling of these
components outside of their quality of
you know being I don't know they have
their own legal requirement for
regulation and I watched California uh
deal with this question since 2019 each
year they were just about to create a
new regime for uh precursor parts and
they even had one at one point but they
use covert to kind of skip ahead and
just accomplish what they wanted anyway
uh you know no spoilers here you're not
allowed to have them but they they ended
up merging precursor Parts with uh the
new enthusiasm for Banning unfinished
receivers because the states the several
liberal blue States ended up mostly just
copying language from bites Ghost Gun
World which we've already discussed here
saying well
whatever's regulated by the ATF it's
regulated here too of a funny
consequence of that is in California for
example right now California laws
really specific to the federal rules so
it says only those things that are
fairly regulated can be sold in
California
well because of vanderstock and the
future summary judgment that's got to
knock out Biden's rule California will
be in this awkward position where
their their law means nothing can be
sold in California because nothing's
federally regulated anymore
is there um is there any room for
federalism in gun laws uh you know for
you uh so you know does California have
the right or Los Angeles or San
Francisco do they have the right to have
different gun laws than uh you know uh
Dallas Texas Austin Huntsville Texas uh
where I spent two years uh you know I
mean is is there a is there room for
that or are these kind of universal
rights which must be universally
respected in all contexts that's not
that's an awesome question uh I think in
Practical terms in Practical political
terms we have to make concessions like
obviously San Francisco is always going
to be hostile in a way that you know
view of Texas is not yeah what I don't
like or at least what I can't accept is
the fact that Newsome and there's this
new these Progressive nostrums mean we
have to empower our state or local
authorities to reach outside of our
state jurisdiction County jurisdiction
Municipal borders and go attack
companies uh and and people in other
states and other jurisdictions so
unfortunately though I would like to
make practical Federal Federalist
concessions in theory right because I
want to be a good American in practice
these are almost impossible to concede
now because there are some something
like Civil War conditions in the courts
and I this is not an exaggeration I
spent most of last year fighting
California because California passed AB
1621 and
70s well I I forget the other ones that
they had but in combination they meant
you know if you're selling something in
Texas like a ghost gun kit we'll just
Empower any of our private citizens or
gun control groups to sue you anyway so
just go just go and sue you so
unfortunately um I think we're we're
kind of in a post Federalist
conversation and um it would be deadly
to just say well I'm a good
constitutional so please everyone in
California please come sue me that was
an excerpt from our live stream with
Cody Wilson if you want to see the full
conversation go here if you want to see
another excerpt go here
and come back next Thursday at 1 pm
eastern time when Zach wisemiller and I
will be talking to somebody very
interesting on the reason live stream